And now to you. Scoutmaster
Brandy Lamb is a scouter down in Florida and she mentioned to me that the seamstress
at REI was kind of getting on her nerves.
You know REI, the camping gear folks.
The seamstress there is getting on Brandy's nerves because she's so intense.
So
That's about par for the course, I would guess.
Hey, this is podcast number 372..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Greene, and rather than waiting around until I get to it right here at the
top of the show, I want to say thanks to everyone who helps me make the podcast possible.
And you can join them, if you like, by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer or patron.
It's easy to do:
Go to scoutmastercgcom and click the support links right there at the top of the page.
Be a backer, be a patron.
I really appreciate it.
There was a lot of response to last week's podcast that kind of devolved into a little
bit of a rant about things, chiefly being the way that the BSA is planning to welcome
girls into the organization this coming February.
If you did not listen to that, let me just give you a short synopsis.
I don't like the way they.
I don't like the way they're doing it,
Because what they're asking is for girls to participate in the BSA. we have to
establish an all girls troop, separate from the all boys troop.
A lot of people, myself included, would rather have just a fully coed troop,
just like most of the rest of the world does.
So let's take a look and see what listeners had to say.
Bus price with troop 349 in Verona, Wisconsin, wrote in to say:
at our district camp are either. this weekend the topic of incorporating young
women into our troops came up.
It seems as though most troops are going to establish the second troop,
have the same key three volunteers and basically function as one troop.
All seem to think this approach is a stepping stone towards truly coed
scouting.
How would you suggest that we approach troop committees about preparing
for this next year?
I think functioning as a single troop is a great idea.
Well, bus, if you look at the FAQ that the BSA published about this-
and I will have a link to it in the podcast notes- it's pretty clear
that establishing a girls troop and having the same key three
volunteers and then functioning as one troop is not really an
option, although I suspect that most people will will do that
and they will be de facto coed, because here's the breakdown.
There's no restriction on having the girls troop and the boys
troop meet in the same place at the same time and even share
an opening and closing ceremony, although the FAQ notes that
they should have separate programs.
There's no restriction against the boys troop and the girls
troop scheduling camping activities together
And, as far as the key three are concerned, the only one that
can't be duplicated for both troops is the scout master.
Girls troops have to have a separate scout master.
So as far as approaching your troop committee is concerned,
I believe it's a great idea if all the members of the
committee are on board with the whole thing, but the ultimate
decision about chartering a girls troop, which is our only
option. There's no option to welcome girls without
chartering a girls troop, and that decision is up to your
chartered partner. So if the chartering organization is
willing to charter a troop for girls, then they can also
help define how it will be administered, whether it will
be under the existing troop committee or if a new
committee needs to be set up, and they can help choose
the scout master for the girls troop.
What I suspect is going to happen, as I said, is people
are going to do all the paperwork and then just function
as a de facto co-ed troop. And that bothers me and that
was the source of my rant last week, because it's kind
of nonsensical. when you get right down to it,
Logistically it's just not a very good idea.
I don't think it's good for our scouts who are
boys. I don't think it's good for our scouts who
are girls. I doubt the BSA is going to direct
councils to monitor and strictly enforce all of this.
I don't know how they would And our volunteers at the
troop level are going to do what makes the most
sense to them. Mike A Ryan Semanovic got in touch
and said: I'm an Eagle Scout, a Wolf Den Leader and
Apprentice Cub Master getting ready to take over the
pack next year. I just discovered your podcast
and I really wanted to say thank you. I can tell
I can learn a lot from you. for the record, I'm
strongly advocating for girls in our pack next year.
I expect that we will have separate dens that meet
at the same time and place and experience the same
activities, while nominally being separate
Again. you know I've just commented on the
whole troop thing. Well, the pack thing is going
to end up the same way. I believe People will
give the whole separate but equal idea a shot
and they will find out that it doesn't work very
well, that it's not a very good thing for boys
or girls and they will end up doing all the
paperwork but not carrying out the policy to
the letter of the law. Mike also asked:
is there any chance you can point me to that
awesome, I am a Sasquatch song from the
last week's show Absolutely. I'll have a link
to it in the podcast notes. That is a song by
a band that's fronted by one of my old
Eagle Scouts whom you've heard here on the
podcast last year, Bucky Kellogg. as Bucky
and Wade were hiking the Appalachian Trail,
The band's called Lost Festingos and you
can find them over at Bandcamp And, like I said,
I'll have a link to it in the podcast notes.
Wayne Wilcox is with Troop and Crew 184
in Cobham, England, If that sounds strange
to you. remember we have a direct service
council for ex-patriots in different
parts of the world. Usually they're in
military or diplomatic service. The BSA
facilitates them being able to have
scout troops just about anywhere in the
world And, as I said, Wayne's over there
in England and Wayne wrote in to say
your thoughts on dealing with older
Scouts are right on the money. It's
been a challenge to keep them engaged
but, as you said, if you give them
scouting to do, then they get on with
it. It's true You can't tell them to
share attempt with little guys. They
really want their own patrol. I give
that to them with the understanding
they'll be there to help the little guys
out when needed. I give them a lot of
responsibility and authority and they
repay me by making me very proud of
them. And that is, Wayne, exactly the
way it works, isn't it? I have a
pretty good retention of older Scouts.
I lose many when they move away
because we have a very transient
community, But the ones who don't move
generally stick around and become
ancestors on their 18th birthdays.
Wayne goes on to say: I listen to
your diatribe at the end and I couldn't
agree more. I've been running a fairly
successful co-ed venture crew
alongside our scout troop
for five years now. When I heard
the BSA was going to invite girls to
become Boy Scouts, I was very happy, only
to have that slip away when I saw
how they were going to do it. As
I'm scouting over here in England, we
have first-hand exposure to the fully
co-ed model. We have a British scout
group that we consider our sister
unit and we do numerous activities
together during the year. I think
we in the BSA could be just
as successful as their program
if given the chance. I think it
should be up to the units to decide
whether co-ed or single sex
is the way they want to go. I think
the BSA will come around eventually.
In the meantime, I don't plan on
unilaterally. I would be very
interested to hear comments
from your other listeners on the way
forward. as always, keep up the great podcast
and keep on scouting Well. thank you, Wayne.
I appreciate those thoughts and,
as we've already heard, I
agree with what you're saying,
And over on Facebook
there were quite a few comments on
the post that contained the podcast
last week. Tim Fox said
I think the past four years have shown
that the BSA is trying to adapt.
Our chartered organization structure is
resilient but it's very inflexible
and this slows down the rate of change.
My guess is the BSA will have co-ed
troops within five years.
This may be unsettling for some,
but it's the only stable outcome.
Bringing girls into our existing
scout troops rather than establishing
new girls troops would be better for
everyone involved because our older
scouts can share their experiences with them.
The BSA plan permits us
to be more conservative
and not have girls admitted at all,
but not more progressive, and that
seems wrong to me. Craig Snodgrass
followed up on that comment by saying-
I've heard quote-unquote:
while separately chartered, a linked
all girls troop may adopt the same
number as an all-boy troop.
If true, this, coupled with the allowance
to meet on the same night, would not
only be fully compliant on paper
but would also help usher the inevitable
move to being
fully co-ed. And I agree with you, Craig-
and as I've said several times,
I think that's the way people are going to do it-
that if you reference the FAQ
that I talked about before,
even though the units are
allowed to meet on the same night, they're supposed to have
separate programs. Dave Goldenberg
wrote in and said thank you
for the rant in last week's podcast.
as a scout master with a venture crew,
I can totally relate. We have challenges
now and I can't imagine
how we're going to make three separate
entities work next year. Lots
of our families were excited,
including my own, that their sisters will
have an opportunity to participate.
The separation of the troops
and units will be frustrating to many,
as many thought we could just add girls
in a co-ed troop.
Your point about ignoring the rules also
hit home. I won't support
just doing what we want to do,
just as I would not support
changes to the requirements.
And yeah, David, I agree
with you. It's very distressing
to me
that the likely outcome of
what is going on
is a result in a lot of people just having
to either
create elaborate justifications
or just paper
tigers and
look like they are obeying
the clearly stated BSA policy,
because every discussion I've been
privy to that is exactly what people
say they're going to do, and
it puts everybody in a very uncomfortable
position and,
as I've always held,
doing that sends a terrible,
terrible message to our
scouts that you can just ignore
this sort of thing and work around it
or justify it when
the way that you're going to do it makes more
sense- And the conundrum here is:
the way that we want to do it
makes more sense-
makes more sense. So
I'm not very happy about all this,
but I'm trying to maintain a good
sense of humor. How about you?
Aaron Hall commented on Facebook and said:
I proclaimed yes, yes, yes.
while listening to last week's podcast,
I'll admit, allowing girls
to join the BSA caught me off guard
at first, but I'm totally
on board now. I don't think
the lack of integration is
going to work And understand.
I'm a scout master who has a daughter in girl
scouts and my wife is a girl
scout troop leader. One of the big problems
with girl scout units is
a lack of trained and willing leaders to take
the girls outdoors, and
this seems like it would also
affect the girl troops unless,
as you suggested, everybody ignores BSA
guidance and just integrates anyway.
Once again, I think I've already made
clear like what my stance is on this
right and how
frustrating it is. I don't suggest
that people just kind of ignore
BSA guidance on the whole thing.
I just see it as being an inevitable
outcome of the way things are headed
Over on Facebook too. Mike
Comnick said in the past
six months I've stumbled on your podcast.
I mean,
I'm a new cub master but
I've been a den leader for several years and let me
say this has been an extremely
helpful. Well thanks, Mike. I'm
always glad to hear that we're being
helpful, even extremely helpful,
and that we're extremely
helpful is even even better news.
Lawrence Wittes commented
on Facebook about last
week's policy. has saying competing
for older scouts, time
seems to be the issue.
Well, I know that that's what
it feels like, but
I'm going to be a little pedantic
and say I learned not to compete
for their time
but to cooperate with all the other activities
that they're involved in. I mean,
for one thing is a way for them
to take what they learn about the scout
oath and law into the wider community
and to apply some of the skills
that they've learned in scouting to the wider
community. and I really
decided that we were not in a
position to compete for
their time and that we should be the most
flexible and accommodating thing on their
schedule, and that really has
unlocked a lot of potential. My older
scouts are extraordinarily helpful and
involved when they can be,
without feeling as though they are
letting us down when they cannot.
So this definitely does not close down
the subject about welcoming girls
into the BSA
at the troop level next
year. I really want to hear
what your thoughts are about that.
but in the remainder of the podcast
we're going to talk about the stated
subject of the podcast and that is
Eagle Scout Advancement. So
let's get started, shall we
Music?
We're going to talk a little bit about
Eagle Scout Advancement Before
we go any further, I want to draw your
attention to something that I
hope you're already following and that is
Bob White Blather.
It's a blog by Scouter Frank
Maynard, and
Frank and I have been communicating
with each other for years. Frank has a
lot of expertise around the troop committee,
served as a troop committee chairman for
a great long time, has a
great deal of experience he can share
with you- and I often refer people to him-
and Frank's latest post
was a synopsis
of what came out from
the National Advancement Team
in this quarter's newsletter.
I will have a link to the newsletter
in the podcast notes, as well
as a link to Frank's
blog and this post in particular.
but one thing
attracted my attention, and it
has to do with Eagle Advancement,
and it's about keeping things simple.
Let me read you what Frank wrote
said. local councils routinely offer
informational sessions on the life to
Eagle process. These are often
accompanied by council specific
publications or outlines listing the
necessary steps that need to be completed
and how things are handled in
that particular council. Indeed,
some troops even have their own
guides to the Eagle process,
while most are brief, outlining things
like the times and places that project
reviews are held and the procedure
for scheduling a board of review.
some extend to dozens of pages
and contain duplicate, outdated, just
plain wrong information
if they are not constantly reviewed
and updated. The Advancement Team
offers advice for those councils and
units that offer such informational
packets. They suggest keeping them
short, limiting the information
to the processes unique to the council
or district, avoid rehashing
information that's contained in other
official BSA publications,
like the guide to Advancement,
and linking to scoutingorg
for copies of forms and documents
rather than posting them on websites
and reviewing everything
periodically to ensure that they conform
to national policies and procedures.
It's especially important they advise
that councils and units don't
intentionally or unintentionally
impose additional requirements
beyond what the BSA specifies.
So make sure to check that out.
and if you want a deep
dive into what goes on in scouting
Advancement, you can get
on the mailing list and get the
National Advancement Team
newsletter that comes out four times a year.
That and an email that I received
this past week, whose sender
asked to remain anonymous, Kind of get
me in the mood to talk about
Eagle Scout for a little bit
and Eagle Scout Advancement.
So, from a logistical and administrative
thing, Eagle Scout Advancement,
to my mind at least,
is way over complicated.
there's just this incredible amount
of paperwork and this labyrinth
of things that sometimes change
very subtly from year to
year and sometimes change
rather dramatically. and
I guess I understand
the rationale
behind the existence of
a lot of this, but really
it's
it's something that
I could go on about,
but when it comes to the
paperwork, logistical,
administrative end of this, keep it simple.
There are two key documents.
there's the Eagle Scout application
and there is the whole
project workbook thing.
The project workbook is fine.
I think it's a little over complicated,
but it's fine. The Eagle application:
again, I think it's a little over
complicated and it's fine.
if you take those two things
and you read them carefully and calmly-
calmly is really important here.
read them calmly
as if you knew nothing
about the process
of becoming an Eagle Scout.
things would immediately make sense.
if you read them in a bit of
a lather and try
to reconcile the tremendous
amount of folklore, mythology
and the downright inaccuracies
that are commonly shared
in casual conversation
amongst Scouters, you're going to find
the whole thing confusing and frustrating.
and this is where
I segue into the answer
to the email that I received,
because talk about confusing and
frustrating Scouters getting wrapped
around their own axle.
Eagle Scout will do that just about every time,
and so
the email I received
was talking about a particular
possible candidate for Eagle Scout
who is very, very close to their
18th birthday and,
in the nature of many 17 year olds,
it's kind of snotty and privileged
and thinks that they can
get all the stuff done that they need to get done.
I've got a Scoutmaster who's like,
wow, I really don't know about this,
and you know, this kid's attitude
is not what I would expect
from somebody who will become
an Eagle Scout, and so they're kind
of analyzing how much work they have
to do and what kind
of merit badge work they have to do.
they're trying to get down
on a granular level with their advice
to the Scout. the Scout, of course,
is being snotty and privileged, like many
17 year olds can be, and not
taking the advice, and so
you know, here's what I have to say
about it. the attention that's being paid
to this is coming from a good
place. it's laudable. okay,
you're trying to be helpful, but you're probably
over involving yourself in things
that I personally, as a
Scoutmaster, have come to regard
as none of my business,
and I want to explain that, because here's
what's going through my mind when I'm working
with the Eagle candidates like the one that you
describe. so you want to take on
10 merit badges in an Eagle project
in the next three months? well, you know what.
you're 17. you know your own mind.
it's none of my business.
I'm going to be skeptical and I'll give
you the benefit of my advice, even though
I know you won't listen, because none of the
Scouts who were just like you
and sat in that chair ever listened
to the advice that I gave them.
and what am I going to say? you know
you're 17. you know you know your own mind.
if this is the way you want to go about
it, it's kind of none of my business,
especially if you
don't care to hear what I have to say about it.
whatever happens next is up to you, and it's
not like this is something we haven't been
talking about for the past several years.
now, if you want to be entitled and
snotty about it, well, there's no need
for me to pile on
the comeuppance that you so
richly deserve and will get
very soon, because it's inevitable. I mean,
I've watched kids like you for many,
many years. you always get some kind
of comeuppance. somebody takes you down
to peg at some point. it may be in Scouts,
maybe out of Scouts, it may not be for a year or
yet, but you're being that snotty and self
centered. this is coming. I don't
need to pile on with it. when that time
comes, if you ask for my help, I'll
be there for you, and I know
all this because this is not my first rodeo.
okay, within the next couple of months, you're
gonna come to me for some kind of help with
your eagle because you got yourself in a
situation I've warned you about. and
you know what. I will not only help you
out. I am going to forgo
pretty much the massive I
told you. so that is mine by right,
because I'm a grown up and you're just a
snotty kid. so, yeah, when you fall
into the chuck hole that I told you
exactly where it was and exactly how you
were gonna fall into it- yep, I'm gonna
help you anyway. and you know what? I'm
even gonna shake your hand at your
quarter of honor with a full heart, even
though you'll probably still be pretty
snotty about the whole thing now in
your later years. maybe you'll reflect
on this time with a little bit of regret
about how self-centered you are and how
you treated people and maybe not
really kind of. none of my business, is it?
the best thing I can do is be your
scoutmaster and give it my best shot.
my aim is to help you. I
don't need to win your thanks or your
respect, and so at first place that
might sound like I'm being a little snotty
myself, but I'm really not okay. I'm
just recognizing that. okay,
there's really not a whole lot of way
that I'm gonna fix this. I'm not gonna
waste my energy on trying to prove
something to this young person because
they're not looking for proof.
I'm gonna help
them. I'm gonna be the, I'm gonna be the
best scoutmaster I can be for them, and
if they're snotty in return, well, what?
what do you expect?
I mean, you're working with 17 year olds
and they're not all that way.
some of them are absolutely wonderful people.
some of them are snotty, privileged little
twerps, and you and I
very well could have been that way
ourselves at that age. so
when we're working with
scouts who are working on
eagle, we get pushed and pulled in all
kinds of directions by the scouts,
by their parents.
we get tangled in the complex
labyrinth of paperwork and
procedures that need to be followed, and many
of us are haunted by the idea that
we must prevent the
undeserving from becoming eagle scouts.
now,
what parents and scouts do and how they
push and pull us around and
the paperwork edicts that come
down from above are way
beyond my control.
that I have to deal with the best
way I can. however,
I can manage my own attitude and reactions
by acknowledging
I am not responsible for quality
control or
responsible for guarding the holy
sanctuary of eagle
against the undeserving.
now that is something that is truly
none of my business, because
nobody
deserves to be an eagle
scout.
I'll say it again: nobody
deserves to be an eagle
scout. now, as a new scout master-
and mind you, this was over 30
years ago- I built up
my own idealized standard of winning
eagle scout ought to be, and
a lot of this was based on the mythology
and lore and
legend of eagle scout dumb.
that has no real
basis in fact,
and these are things that are routinely discussed
and agreed to by many
scouters, but they
they're just nothing factual
about them. and man, I got
a snoot full of that as a young scout
master and I said: nobody is
going to get eagle unless they meet my standards.
now the problem is is. I
hadn't actually answered the question:
what is an eagle scout?
I've been struck, distracted
by a very different issue,
and that is: who deserves
to be an eagle scout? I thought that I needed
to be the judge of that. so the answer to
the question of who deserves to be an eagle
scout is easy, because
it's any scout who completes the
requirements. that's it. there's no more
and there's no less. there's no eagle
plus and no eagle minus, only
eagle. and the way you become an eagle
scout is what: you complete the requirements.
during my tenure as scout master,
I was very privileged
to present somewhere north of
100 and south of 120 eagle
scout badges. so how did
that go? all of the
scouts who received eagle during my tenure
completely measured up to that idealized,
dramatically operatic and
totally unnecessary standard
that I created for myself. but
I learned that that didn't matter. and I
can tell you something: none of the
55,494
eagle badges handed out last
year went to a scout because they
deserved it. no,
each one of them received a badge
because they earned it.
nobody becomes an eagle scout because
they deserve it. eagle scout is not the
Nobel prize or the Pulitzer.
that's just awarded to a choice
deserving few. when a
scout fulfills all the requirements and passes
a duly constituted border
review, they receive
the eagle scout badge.
so it is not your job or my job
to decide who deserves
the badge, only to recognize
that they've completed the requirements.
the 55,494
scouts did not do precisely the same
quality or quantity of
work to earn the award last year,
nor were they all equally meritorious.
each had individual
limitations and talents. each had
their own set of parents, their own
set of issues. they worked with
scouts who involvement and skill were all over
the map. I believe a healthy
percentage of them, if
experiences means anything,
were kind of snotty, privileged youngsters
who left a lot of work to the last
few months of their 17th year,
but they completed the requirements.
they get the badge now. when we present
an eagle badge, we recognize
two things: achievement-
they completed the requirements-
and potential.
we are telling a scout that
what you have achieved is
a strong indication that
you have the potential
to embody the ideals
that this award
represents, because I think
the important thing to realize is that
once a scout earns an eagle badge,
he begins the life long
process of becoming
an eagle scout. not one of
the 2.7 million or so
young people who have earned
the rank were an ideal,
fully formed eagle scout when
somebody handed them the badge.
that badge is just a doorway to a
lifetime of opportunities ahead of them.
we've recognized a measure of potential
and character in them and the rest
is up to them. my first eagles
are well into their 40s now
and I'm privileged that many of them still keep in contact
with me. it's one of the great
joys of my life. and each of them
is busy becoming an eagle
scout every single day, because that's what
an eagle scout does. our job
is seeing to it that every one of
our scouts has a chance to complete
the requirements for eagle. that way,
they can spend the rest of their lives
becoming an eagle scout, and we're responsible
to clear the way as best we can,
to offer what advice we can
and to let the scout do the rest.
you're gonna run into the maddening,
indifferent,
snotty little twerp sometimes,
but remember they're just kids
still trying to figure things out
and you're the adult. you should have
a little more experience and perspective than they do,
let's hope. and if you really want
to spin your wheels and get wrapped around your own
axle, get in a power struggle
with a snotty, privileged
17 year old see how that
goes for you.
one of the things I
began to understand about this whole thing
was that as an adult, I was
also confronting the
ghosts of my own 17 year old
self when I saw it in my
scouts. because
I don't care who you are, you do
and say some things at
that age that are so
very, very stupid.
you know, I mean
we need a lot of
forbearance and forgiveness
to make it past the age of 20
that our parents, our teachers,
our friends didn't just
strangle us in our sleep
some days. you know that's
a miracle, and so when
we're working with candidates for
eagle, your attitude and your perspective
is very, very important. we're gonna keep
things as simple and direct as possible.
we're gonna be as helpful as possible.
we're gonna be as understanding as possible
and trying to be
the adult you wish you
had to help you at that age, rather
than one who has
something to prove. because if you
imagine a scenario where
you hold the hard line and you're kind
of a hard head about things and you're mean
and you
are going to take that snotty little
17 year old down a peg,
well, good luck with that. you
can make them knuckle under if you want, but
you can't win their hearts and minds that way,
and if you're understanding and
passionate and, like I said,
try to be the adult that helps them,
rather than one has something to prove
to them, you know what
they very well may come back to at some
point when they're a little bit older,
they've seen a little bit more of the world,
and say: you know, I was kind of snotty
about the whole thing and I really thank you
for the attitude that you had. and maybe,
not
probably much more likely, that's never
gonna happen. it's happened to me a couple of times.
it's been very nice probably,
but it's not gonna happen. but under which
scenario are you going to feel
like you've been closer
to being an example of the scout
oath and law? huh, yeah, I think the answer
is pretty clear. hey, we all got a lot of work
to do, don't we? I'd like you to get in touch
with me and let me know what you think about this
week's podcast and all of the ongoing
issues we've been discussing. I'm gonna tell
you how to do that in just a moment.
Thank you for listening to this
372nd edition
of the scout master podcast.
as promised, I want to tell you how to keep in touch,
go over to scoutmastercgcom.
there's lots of articles and law and the
entire archive of the past editions
of the podcast, and you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
and the podcast by email.
you can join us in the vast panoramic
podcast and you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
and the podcast by email. you can
join us in the vast panorama
of social media outlets
over on Facebook and on Twitter.
you can use the contact form at the website
to get in touch or you can just
fire up that old IBM
Pentium desktop with
the CRT screen and
tap out a good old fashioned email.
I'm always available at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at
scoutmastercgcom.
I want to remind you
I am not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America or any other
scouting organization for that matter.
Nope, this is just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to my fellow
scouts in the best way that I know how,
and you know we're going to have a little
bit of fun if we can, and speaking of which,
let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert
Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good hunting,
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.
Bye.